hey brandon hi how are you i
am good thank you for chatting with me
on et canada pride big mouth
season four is coming i can't say too
much
but i've seen all of season four and i
don't want a lawsuit so i can't do
anything but you but you can
you uh co-wrote an episode you also do a
voice
in season four congratulations on that
what can you tease the fans with
i can tell you about as much as you can
tell me honey
i'm not trying to get sued either no i
can tell you that it's gonna be a fun
season and that we're gonna
you know dive into uh some
deeper stories with some of our favorite
characters like missy
and matthew in the time that we're in
right now where we're talking about
inclusion and diversity and
and telling stories from povs of people
of color and queer people
we definitely get into that in season
four you know there aren't a lot of
shows where queer characters get to be
the center of their stories
or where they're not um in this
oppression-based narrative
you know where our characters just kind
of get to be full and our core
characters do
and really get to be themselves and
navigate
their queerness but other things as well
their friendships their relationships
navigating
school um and trying to not make their
queerness the center of everything but
part of it just like you know microness
is not the center of everything it's a
part of the land
there's a spin-off coming up called
human resources that's so exciting
you are also writing on that series as
well as
voicing a character i know you probably
can't tell me
too much but why not you were trying to
[Laughter]
well okay listen tell me about voicing a
character like has that been a dream for
you since you started your career in
entertainment really
it wasn't a dream to start but it
definitely
came about especially as i got into big
mouth because animation
is such a fun and incredible uh space to
tell
stories that you just can't do in live
action you know i'm so used to
being on camera but just being able to
use my voice to express a story
so it's been exciting well you've been
doing a fantastic job
of amplifying black and queer voices
thank you for that you have a series
called black folks
but you have a new series coming very
soon
called do the work so let me start this
off by asking you a question
have you ever had an awkward moment
around race
with someone you love do the work is a
podcast uh
where we basically take people who are
friends or lovers or family members
who have had a discrepancy or
an issue around race and we
talk about what that issue is how it
came to be and break down
what is wrong with that moment uh and
then bring the couple together to have a
conversation that is hopefully healing
and moving forward
and i think it's important just because
you know as we talk about
systems and like policies and government
we also still need to be talking about
our relationships with each other the
amount of
conversation that has happened in 2020
regarding black lives
black trans lives how are you feeling
about
things now in 2020 are you seeing
a change yet good question uh yes
and no i mean you know i think that what
we've seen is an uh
up and down right we saw this like kind
of surge of
interest and posting and all this stuff
and then we've seen a really massive dip
in terms of
people being plugged in the reality is
it's challenging it's hard it's
depressing it's devastating
but this is the experience of black
people this is the experience of black
queer people
every day it's what we're wrestling with
and so you know
i think that we just need people to
white people specifically to
recommit every single day to recognize
and empathize with what's at stake which
is the lives of people that you care
about but as
my therapist always says you don't
really have anything without optimism
right
if you don't have hope you can't really
do anything so
where i am if i'm hopeful i'm optimistic
and i'm gonna
hold on to that for as long as i
possibly can
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos